JUSTIN MAHOOD: Hi,
I'm Justin Mahood.
I'm a product manager
on Cloud Run for Anthos.
ADAM KANE: And I'm Adam Kane.
I'm an engineering manager
on Cloud Run for Anthos.
JUSTIN MAHOOD: And
we're here today
to show you how to build a
scalable web application using
Cloud Run for Anthos on GKE.
So first, I'll give
you an overview
of Cloud Run for Anthos,
which is the technology that's
at the core of the sample that
we want to show you today.
Then, we'll talk through
some of the problems
that you'll need to solve when
standing up an enterprise web
application and a
Kubernetes environment.
And then we'll walk through
our sample architecture
and talk about the different
tools in the Anthos and GKE
ecosystem that
you'll use to deliver
this kind of application.
And then, finally, I'll
give you a short demo
of how to deploy
our sample directly
into your GCP environment.
So let's introduce you
to the product that's
at the core of this sample,
Cloud Run for Anthos.
When developing
web applications,
serverless patterns
are very, very popular.
And why is that?
Well, there's the
operational model.
You don't have to worry
about infrastructure.
It's inherently scalable.
And you pay for what you use.
But for developers, it's
really the programming model
that's attractive.
They also don't have to worry
about the infrastructure
management.
And fundamentally,
it's optimized
for service-based architectures,
like web applications.
But at the same time,
we've got Kubernetes,
which is now the de facto
platform for running containers
in the enterprise and the de
facto enterprise operations
platform in general.
So what if we can
have the benefits
of a serverless
development platform
with all of the control and
flexibility of Kubernetes?
And that's exactly why we
created Cloud Run for Anthos.
You can also think of
Cloud Run for Anthos
as Kubernetes the easy way.
Developers get that
serverless experience
where they can focus
on their application
and their application
logic, rather
than worrying about the
intricacies of Kubernetes
deployments and all
of the Kubernetes
concepts that go along with it.
So you can say that
Cloud Run for Anthos
gives you the best
of both worlds.
It gives you the
best of serverless.
You can run any standard
Docker container.
It has request-based
auto scaling.
It's very fast and
scales down to zero.
It includes incremental
rollouts and rollback
so you can do things like
blue-green deployments
and roll back for production.
And it also has a whole suite
of monitoring and logging tools
that are built in for the
developer out of the box.
And at the same time,
the operations team
gets all the benefits of
Kubernetes environment.
The flexibility and
control that comes
with GKE, integrated
policy support, the ability
to run your compute completely
within a VPC, custom note types
and customization of
the underlying hardware,
and the extensive toolset
that the Kubernetes ecosystem
provides.
And I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention
that Cloud Run for Anthos
is based on the Knative Open
Source Project.
This is an open
source project that
was started by Google with
contributions from over 80
companies.
And really, what
this guarantees is
that the workloads
that you write
and architect for
Cloud Run for Anthos
are portable between
Knative environments
and whichever cloud platform
you ultimately end up choosing.
So now let's talk about actually
building and architecting
a web application.
So let's imagine for a moment.
You're a developer in
an e-commerce company.
GKE and Kubernetes
is the ops platform
that your company has
chosen and standardized on.
And you're given a task with
delivering a line of business
web application for tracking
your warehouse inventory
on a pretty tight timeline.
So it's Monday morning.
You sit down with
your cup of coffee.
You sharpen your pencil.
And you start sketching
out the architecture
that you're going to use.
And this is sort of what's
in your head to begin with.
You know that it's
going to run in GCP.
You know that
there's going to be
a web application of some kind.
And you know that
it ultimately needs
to run on both desktop,
laptop, and mobile devices.
But then you really
start to break it down.
You know you're going
to need a frontend.
You're know you're going to
need a backend and a database
to store your state.
You start breaking
it down some more.
And some more requirements
really start to come into view.
Since your company is
standardized on GKE,
you're going to use
Cloud Run for Anthos
for your backend
services for all
of those serverless benefits
in the Kubernetes platform
we talked about earlier.
And also, you know you're going
to need to access and modify
data in a database
in a secure fashion.
So in addition to using
Firestore as a database,
you want to be able to use your
Kubernetes service identities
for this authentication.
And it'd be remiss if you
hadn't thought a little bit
about how load balancing and
your URLs were going to work.
And you realize because you
want to serve your frontend
from a [INAUDIBLE]
storage bucket,
but have your backend
services running
in Cloud Run for
Anthos, you need the app
to be on a single
endpoint and subdomain
for [INAUDIBLE] reasons.
And you need path-based routing
between the frontend served
from GCS and your
multiple backend services
running on Cloud Run for Anthos.
And also, your enterprise
has a hard core requirement
that everything needs to
be HTTPS out of the box,
as it should be, and that
your GKE cluster can't
be connected to the internet.
And finally, as the
last requirements
start to come into
view, you realize
that you need to make sure this
web application is accessible
only by employees.
They absolutely have
to authenticate.
And they need to use your
company's federated identity
provider.
Also, there's different
role-based features
for workers and managers
of the warehouse.
So you need to have role-based
access and an authorization
platform for each call
that goes through.
And you're going to
use Istio for that.
So after a couple of weeks
of hard work of architecting
and writing the
application, you're
ready to hand it off and
start managing inventory
in your warehouse, using
an application you designed
to run on Cloud Run for Anthos.
But you sort of
thought to yourself,
it sure would be
great if there was
a blueprint for all of this.
And it turns out that there is--
the Cloud Run for Anthos
Reference web application.
You see the link.
It's hosted up there
on GitHub today.
And it's an opinionated
set of best practices
aimed at demonstrating
a reference architecture
for building an enterprise
grade web application on GCP,
using Cloud Run for Anthos.
So now I'm going to kick
it over to my friend, Adam.
And he's going to
take you through each
of the components
of the architecture
that we talked about
a little bit earlier
and go into a deep dive
about how we implement those
and how you can implement
them in your environment.
Adam?
ADAM KANE: Thank you, Justin.
As Justin mentioned,
I'm going to walk you
through a little bit of a deeper
look at some of the decisions
that we've made in implementing
our reference web application.
So we'll start with a quick
overview of the reference
architecture that we've used.
The goal of our
reference application
is to simulate a line of
business web application that's
built around the Cloud
Run for Anthos platform.
The subject matter of our
application in this case
is inventory management.
But this is mostly arbitrary.
The goal of this application
is to provide a reference
for implementing
common web application
patterns using
Cloud Run for Anthos
in combination with
other GCP services.
In this case, we've
implemented the application
using Angular and Go.
But the infrastructure patterns
that we demonstrate here
are not specific
to these languages.
So as a quick overview
of the architecture,
it's comprised of a frontend UI
and multiple backend stateless
services.
It's exposed through
a Google Cloud load
balancer, which provides
a consolidated endpoint
to our end user.
The frontend UI is statically
served from a GCS bucket.
And our backend
services are hosted
using Cloud Run for Anthos.
End user authentication
and authorization
of our backend API requests are
handled by Istio in combination
with the Google
Identity Platform.
And our application
state is stored
in the Firestore database.
Let's now take a look in
a little bit more detail
about each of the three
major infrastructure patterns
that we've used in our
reference application.
First, we'll talk
about the database
that stores state
for our application.
Of course, our
backend services need
to be able to access and modify
the data in this database
in a secure fashion.
Ideally, we should be able
to access this database using
the service identities
for our backend services
and not have to manage explicit
secrets or other authentication
tokens.
We use Firestore in this case,
which is compatible with GCP IM
authentication.
But this discussion is really
relevant to any database
or service, which provides
authentication using IAM.
Our backend services,
because they're
running on Cloud Run for Anthos
are bound to Kubernetes Service
Accounts, or KSAs.
We use a feature of GKE called
Workload Identities to bind
these Kubernetes Service
Accounts to Google Service
Accounts, or GSAs, in IAM.
Once this binding
is in place, we
can apply our access
permissions for our database
to the Google Service accounts.
And through workload
identity, these permissions
apply transitively to our
Kubernetes Service Accounts.
Once we've enabled
workload identities
on our Cloud Run
for Anthos cluster,
binding service accounts
is a two-step process
that requires action
in both GKE and IAM.
In GKE, each Kubernetes
service account
is annotated with the GCP
service account annotation,
which specifies the
Google Service account
that we are binding the
Kubernetes service account to.
In IAM, a policy binding is
created against the Google
Service Account.
And this policy binding
specifies the Kubernetes
Service Account
and the namespace
that that Google service
account will be bound to.
If you're paying
close attention here,
you'll notice that we don't
specify a specific GKE cluster
with this policy binding.
This is because workload
identity bindings
apply to all Kubernetes
Service Accounts, which
reside in a matching
namespace across all clusters
in the target project.
This is an important
detail to consider
when you're thinking about how
to manage your GCP resources
in your project structure.
But keep in mind that the
binding will only take effect
if the Kubernetes Service
Account is also annotated
as described here.
Next, we're going
to look a little bit
into how we have solved load
balancing and request routing.
So just a quick reminder about
our requirements, in this case,
we want to have a single
endpoint and a single subdomain
for our application.
We need path-based
routing to route requests
between our frontend
and our backend service.
Our enduser traffic should
be secured with HTTPS.
And to avoid exposing
our cluster ingress
to the internet, we would
like to restrict access
to cluster ingress if possible.
It would also be very nice if we
could use Kubernetes resources
to manage all of our load
balancing infrastructure
for the application.
Let's see in a little
bit more detail
how we've addressed these
requirements in our reference
web app.
In this diagram, you can
see the resource layout
for the load balancer used in
our reference web application.
If you're not
familiar with GCLB,
this diagram probably looks
a little bit intimidating.
But we'll break it down
over the next few slides
and look at each
section in more detail.
At the heart of
our load balancer
is what's known as a URL map.
And our URL map
defines an association
between request paths
and backend resources.
In this case, our URL map
includes a default route
to a backend bucket
associated with the GCS
bucket that contains our
static application assets.
It also includes
past specific routes
to multiple backend
services, which
are each mapped to
individual Cloud Run
for Anthos services
running on our cluster.
By default, a custom
host header is
required to ensure that requests
received by the cluster ingress
are sent along to the correct
service on our cluster.
In this case, we're using GCLB
to inject these host header
values and to make sure
that our requests are
sent to the appropriate
service on the cluster.
In the case of the
reference application,
we've configured our load
balancer to terminate SSL.
We've used a Google-managed
SSL certificate for this case.
Because our end
user traffic always
starts at the GCLB endpoint,
our cluster ingress
doesn't need to be exposed
directly to the internet.
Traffic to the
ingress of the cluster
can be restricted
to only be allowed
from trusted
sources such as GCLB
as well known ingress ranges.
This can be achieved through
either using a private cluster,
or, as in the case with
our reference application,
using firewalls to restrict
where that traffic can
originate from.
When you provision our
reference web application
with the automation
we've included in GitHub,
it will actually
automatically apply
these ingress traffic rules to
restrict access to the cluster.
There's a lot of individual
resources to provision
and manage with a load
balancer like this.
The config connector, or
KCC, provides the ability
to manage all of these
resources using KRM.
And they do this by defining
Kubernetes CRDs for each
of these GCP resources.
In the case of our
reference application,
we install KCC on
the same cluster used
to host our backend services.
Infrastructure for
our application
can then be
provisioned and managed
by creating KCC resources
on the same cluster.
You can reference and reuse
any of the infrastructure
configuration that we talk
about in this presentation
by referencing the KRM
in our GitHub repository.
You can connect
Cloud Run for Anthos
to a GCLB load balancer using
a standalone Network Endpoint
Group, or an NEG.
Cloud Run for Anthos uses Istio
to manage its request ingress
to the cluster.
Even when you don't
explicitly install Istio,
we package a minimal
version of it
with Cloud Run for Anthos when
you install it on the cluster.
All requests that are
bound for user services
on your Cloud Run
for Anthos cluster
first arrive at what's called
the Istio Ingress Gateway
Service on the
cluster and are then
routed from there to the
appropriate user service.
To connect to GCLB, we are going
to create a Network Endpoint
Group associated with the
ingress gateway on our cluster.
To do this, we add a
cloud.google.com/neg annotation
to the Istio ingress
gateway service resource.
And this is just a standard
Kubernetes service resource.
In response, GKE will add
the NEG status annotation
automatically to that
service resource.
And this annotation
will include the ID
and the zone of the associated
network endpoint group.
We'll now create a backend
service to associate
with this Network
Endpoint Group.
We want to bind our GCLB backend
service to a specific end user
service on the cluster.
So we configure
the backend service
with a custom request
header for the host header
field of the request.
Cloud Run for Anthos uses
this host header value
to determine where to route
the requests once they
arrive at the Istio
ingress gateway service.
All of the requests,
as a result, forwarded
to this backend service will
arrive at our desired user
service on the cluster.
The Network Endpoint Group
is then added as a backend
to this backend service
using its ID end
zone that we received
from the GKE annotation.
In this case, the
backend service
is associated with
food.example.com.
And we can now include
this backend service
in the URL map of
our load balancer,
so that we can route
requests to it.
In the examples
on this slide, we
showed G Cloud commands to
provision these resources.
But it's also
possible to provision
these resources using
config connector.
You can see an
example of this if you
look at the care and resources
in our GitHub repository.
Finally, we're
going to cover how
we handle end user
authentication
and authorization for the
reference application.
As a refresher, we're
building an application here
for internal use by employees.
So it's important that we
authenticate each end user that
arrives at our application.
We would like to use a
federated identity provider.
And we'd also like to
implement email and password
authentication as well.
We're going to need
role-based authorization
to allow us to limit
access to certain features
on the application,
based on a custom user
role assigned to each user.
In this case, users can be
either workers or managers.
Let's take a look
at how we've solved
authorization and authentication
on our reference application.
So we've chosen to use Google
as our federated identity
provider.
This allows end users to
sign into the application
with their Google account.
We've also implemented email
and password authentication.
However, this is
mostly to easily enable
certain testing scenarios.
Covering how this
works end-to-end,
when a user authenticates
with our application,
they receive a JSON Web Token.
And this JSON Web Token
is used by the frontend
to make API calls to
our backend services.
When a request arrives at
the Istio Ingress Gateway,
Istio is configured to validate
these tokens with the GCP
Identity Platform
and also enforce
role-based authorization
for various methods and APIs
on our backend services.
Here, you can see an example
of the Istio authentication
policy created to
validate these JSON Web
Tokens against the
Google Identity Platform.
In this case, it applies to all
requests with paths that begin
with the /API prefix.
We also configure
authorization in this case
with Istio resources.
And you can see an
example of that here.
In this case, this
policy authorizes access
to the POST method of
the inventory transaction
API for end users with
the role type worker.
All of the authentication
and authorization resources
used in our
reference application
can be found in our
GitHub repository.
I'm now going to hand
it over to Justin
for a demo of how to provision
the reference web application
in your GCP project.
JUSTIN MAHOOD: Now
I'm going to give you
a quick demo of how easy it is
to get the sample up, running,
and deployed into your GCP
project, directly from GitHub.
As you can see here, I am
on the GitHub repository
for the sample application.
And here is the Read Me.
And this Read Me actually has
a step by step walkthrough
and includes scripts that
will get the sample built
and deployed into your cluster,
which I'm going to show
you a little bit of right here.
You can see there's a big blue
button that says Opening Google
Cloud Shell.
What this actually does is,
it clones this repository
in your GCP Cloud Shell VM.
And from here, you
can edit the code.
And then follow along
with the Read Me
to deploy it right into
your GCP environment.
So I've already got this
set up ahead of time.
But what I am going to do is
go ahead and run the included
script to kick off Cloud
Build and get the application
deployed in my environment.
I'm going to kick off a make.
And as you can see, it's
getting started there.
And I'm going to hop
over here to Cloud Build,
and you'll see that that
has triggered a Cloud Build.
It should be running now.
You can see that that build is
running from what I kicked off
in Cloud Shell there.
And it's fetching the source
from the latest commit.
Now, given this is going to
take a little bit of time
to set up, go through
all of these steps
and set up the
infrastructure, I'm
going to skip ahead in time to
a build that I already completed
and show you that I've
got the backend services
for the application running
in Cloud Run for Anthos.
And you can see
that there's a user
service and a backend service
for different components
of the API that the
application is calling.
And over the last hour,
you can see some metrics.
Hasn't been a whole
lot of utilization
because I just spun this up.
But you can see
the request count,
the number of containers, the
instances for the backend,
et cetera.
And then finally, I can
actually just show you
the application
running live here.
I can click the G
button to log in.
Now I've logged
in, and it's going
to load the inventory of items.
Here we go.
Perfect.
So to sum everything
up, Cloud Run for Anthos
gives you the best of
serverless development patterns
in a Kubernetes environment.
By integrating with the
suite of other GCP services,
it's possible to implement
an enterprise-ready web
application using
Cloud Run for Anthos
and the rest of the
Anthos in GKE ecosystem.
And finally, everything
we just showed
you is open source and
available on GitHub
for you to try and deploy
into your own GCP environment.
So on behalf of Adam and
everyone here at Google Cloud,
we want to thank you for
watching our presentation.
And I hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day.